machine learning it's a buzzword but I
would also claim it's a lot more than
just a buzzword how many have experience
with machine learning it's a small
portion area it's great to see when I
started learning machine learning I
found it difficult to understand how the
different algorithm worked and what the
main difference between them was I find
it really difficult understand where I
should start to learn machine learning
but in this lightning speech you
hopefully will learn fundamental
difference between different categories
of algorithms
this will helpful both beginners with
also those who there who have a little
experience with machine learning all
right so real quick about myself my name
is Joakim Lyon I'm a consultant here in
Oslo for the Nordic consulting firm
knowit's and I've been fascinated with
machine learning for the last couple of
years doing some project both personally
and professionally and I must say there
are many different algorithms out there
just take a look at this this is a small
portion of really great algorithms so
where they begin obviously some
algorithms are more suited for certain
problems that others and the result will
vary greatly of how well your algorithm
is suited for a problem but luckily you
can divide these algorithms into four
different categories of machine learning
so the four different categories is
supervised learning and supervised
learning semi-supervised learning and
reinforcement learning and when you face
a machine learning problem it is
important to understand which category
it fits into so today we're going to
explore these four different categories
before we get through really good stuff
I need to explain two key words there in
machine learning you have something
called features this is basically a
property of your training data and a
label is the output you get from your
model after training it so you could say
features input levels output it's
partially true because you can also have
labels on your input data I'm gonna
explain that with an example let's say
you want the machine learning algorithm
to estimate the height of a person based
on age and gender
then age and gender are features and the
height you want to find is the label
and if you have a training set with a
lot of people with their height
corresponding to age and gender then you
have a labeled training set so the first
category is called supervised learning
and in supervised learning you have
training data that consists of a set of
training examples you have a labeled
training set and the basic idea is to
find the most optimal model parameters
to predict unknown labels on other
objects let's look at a few examples
let's say I want to estimate the value
of a used car
based on age mark the mileage you name
it then a machine learning algorithm can
do this pretty well if you give it a
training set with a lot of Sol cars with
the corresponding value another example
could be a mail it spammers it not spam
a machine learning algorithm can do this
if it has a large training sets a great
algorithm within the supervised domain
is called decision trees the reason I
picked this one is because it's more
intuitive than most others so in
decision trees you have nodes and in
every node you choose the best split
between a lot of features and you make
this procedure recursively until we
finish with the stopping criteria again
I'm gonna illustrate this with an
example let's say you want to find out
we should accept a new job offer the
first thought might be well how much is
the salary is it above some threshold if
it's not you're definitely not gonna
take the job but if it is then do you
have to commute for a long while do they
are free coffee we'd have a food table I
don't know you might ask yourself
questions like this but at some point
you can end up and of stopping leaf and
I'm gonna either accept or decline the
job offer
so that was supervised learning next
category is called unsupervised learning
and then unsupervised learning you only
have input data and no corresponding
output variables you have no labels in
your training sets and the goal phone
supports learning is to model the
underlying structure or distribution in
the data in order to learn more about
the data so the algorithms are left on
their own to discover and present the
interesting structures in the data let's
look at a couple examples let's see you
want to group customers by their
purchasing behavior people buy item 810
to buy item B then obviously you should
recommend these items to people
interested in one of them
another example could be in Netflix
Netflix video recommendation system it
recommends TV series movies and whatnot
and they do this by using a series of
unsupervised learning algorithms a great
algorithm here is called k-means not for
Netflix maybe but for other purposes and
here we try to divide all the data into
K clusters and you select random K
points in new clusters and in the
Centers and the cluster of other objects
are defined by the closest cluster
Center you tune this algorithm by
selecting the K number of clusters you
can use this algorithm for many things
let's say you have not hotel chain
anyone to open a new hotel in a city
where do you place your hotel
hopefully you start off by looking at
potential sites gather a lot of data
like we see close to downtown the
restaurants nearby is it easy to get to
the hotel and so on and maybe hopefully
from all this data and algorithm can
find clusters in this data to show
interesting spots for your tab
so most unsupervised learning third
category of problems falls between
unsupervised and supervised problems and
it's called semi-supervised learning
here we have partially labeled data and
many real problems fall into this
category because it can be really
expensive or at least time-consuming to
try to label all the data let's save a
million pictures and you're gonna label
them takes too much time
unlabeled data however is cheap and
usually easy to collect and store so
here a mixture of techniques from the
unsupervised unsupervised domain can be
used an example here could be as I
already mentioned if you have a photo
archive you might label some of the
images like there's a cat in this
picture people skiing topless person on
the beach I don't know
and from this label pictures you have a
lot of unlabeled pictures and you can
try to label those with an algorithm so
the last category of problems fall into
reinforcement learning and it's not like
any of the supervised learning
algorithms because you don't have any
label data and you don't have any
unlabeled data usually you don't have
any training data the idea is to create
a software agent and it's got some
states and it's gonna perform some
action in environments
the environment is gonna either punish
it or reward it somehow and they can end
up in new state and you do this
recursively and you can imagine this by
saying you're a robot and you wake up
and in a strange place you can perform
activities and you're gonna get rewards
from the environment so after you get
more rewards you get more clever and
your actions get more complex and you're
training to behave the most effective
way on each step so this is kind of a
human way to learn and human way to
think and we made some incredible
progress within the reinforcement domain
last years as first speaker mentioned
alphago was a great great example here
they managed to be the best player in
the Google ingo and the reason why I
bring this up is because it made some
moves that humanity has never seen
before and they now teach some of the
moves it did during the game at go
schools in China they have go schools in
China which is surprising and I find it
really interesting that humans can now
learn from machine and not just the
other way around another really cool
example I think is from pretty recent
time from open AI they managed to create
an AI that could beat some of the best
players in the world in dota 2 and dota
2 is a real-time game so the world was
quite shocked to see that this happen
already we fought this was the years and
years until it could happen because it's
vastly more complex than traditional
board games like chess and this is my
personal dream project I'm really hoping
I can beat myself but by creating an AI
that can beat me in Mario Kart and not
to brag but I'm quite good at Mario Kart
so I'm not sure if I'm program skills is
cute enough we'll see so hopefully the
last 10 minutes you learned what's here
in supervised learning all there is
labeled and the algorithm learns to
predict the output from the input data
when unsupervised learning all there is
unlabeled and the algorithm learns the
inherent structure from the input data
semi-supervised learning have some data
labeled some unlabeled mostly unlabeled
and a mixture of supervised and
unsupervised techniques can be used
reinforcement learning is an area of
machine learning concerned with how a
soft region out to take action in
environment so as to maximize some
notion of cumulative reward so as I said
in the beginning machine learning might
be a buzzword but it's happening right
now
to just go out there and learn it thank
you everybody
[Applause]